good evening and welcome to the 59th
annual Academy Awards Show my name is
Chevy Chase and I must say I feel
privileged to be your host this evening
actually I'm one of your co-hosts well
that's not true I'm really a replacement
star to have to tell you that Jim and
Tammy Baker couldn't make it
apparently she's taking some kind of a
trip and he had to be part of some major
affair so
you know I was up in my prayer tower
this morning and funny thing happened I
was talking with you-know-who and he
said to tell you that I have to raise
$15,000 before the shows or he's gonna
call me home so what do you mean call me
how what what if I'm not there should I
leave my machine on anyway I've told you
so I've done my part and you've got to
the end of the show to do your part
that's more than enough time
it's only 15 grand and you're all rich
1.3 million you're all poor
I want to thank Paul Hogan for flying
all the way down under to be here in
Hollywood where when we say throw
another shrimp on the barbie means we're
getting rid of our agents
to the sequel kangaroo dundee but i also
want to give special thanks to shirley
maclaine i'm not a kook but I do believe
in reincarnation in fact I used to be
Shirley it's a lot of yucks
very tiring so this is kind of like deja
vu for me this year saw a tremendous
change in Hollywood big corporations
moved in and bought the network's and
the movie studios one giant firm now
manufactures both television shows and
garbage disposals and sometimes gets the
two confused
Columbia studios are bought by coca-cola
they got rid of 14 executives and a 7up
machine I've noticed the Disney Studios
has started to make a few risque
pictures I took my kids to the movie the
other day and I saw a Mickey Mouse
wearing a raincoat
and the salaries of the stars are
startling now Golan and Globus of kena
films paid Sylvester Stallone twelve
million dollars for his last picture
they were under the impression that the
money for the Contras is being diverted
to them
the pictures nominated this year are
truly wonderful very now very 80s the
mission the story of the liberation of
the Durrani Indian tribe and the jungles
of South America mapped out at a corner
table of the Polo Lounge at the Beverly
Hills Hotel platoon a recruiting film
for conscientious objectors I turned
that one down I was up for it children
of a lesser God I'll make love and a
swimming pool without waking the
neighbors their sisters in which Woody
Allen plays a hypochondriac and Michael
clean plays with the sisters of course a
room with the view was a special picture
made with a small budget that has become
a tremendous hip it's about a rooming
house in Italy where the producer lives
in a small room happily looking down at
the grosses of Howard the Duck turn that
one out too
so Paul and Shirley and all of you out
there welcome to Monday Night Live when
the most important secrets in Hollywood
are contained in briefcases held by two
men whose complete silence can be
depended upon Poindexter and north
now I especially want to welcome the
nominees tonight a lot has been said
about the length of the show
particularly in the acceptance speeches
we're asking you to keep your speeches
under one minute because we're on ABC if
they wanted long rambling speeches they
rerun America
this year we've instituted a kind of a
early warning system rather than a host
I'm going to kind of be a ringmaster out
here you want to keep the show rolling
so if we feel you're getting a little
long
you'll hear a warning sound like so ten
seconds after that there'll be another
warning excuse me in the extreme cases
you will hear